thank you
it is time now for CBS yields this
morning and we're going to take you to
look at some cozy Treats they're going
to treat you to Nimble on or a little
something for a furry family member we
have lots going on here and it's all
exclusive discounts so to start shopping
scan that QR code on your screen or
visit
cbsdeals.com lifestyle expert Ashley
Bellman joins us with more and she's
wearing the good rocking the produce
Lifestyle brand jumpsuit this is the
most comfortable loungewear you have to
try it the deals are great today
starting at 37.50 25 off they have
everything and I'm telling you this is
like you get out of your pajamas and
into your loungewear you could lounge
around the house in the t-shirts in the
pants in the sweatshirts really nice
sayings on them too vegan line Pita
approved also really Oprah approved her
favorite things list wow I I want you to
be like touch this it is so okay I don't
want to get in any trouble
nice but you know you have to have the
figure come on oh my gosh no please
you're looking great there you look
great in your Pudu amazing thank you
what's next so I am a dog mom and
anytime we walk out as you know you have
a million things you're like oh just
grab the leash and the keys and the
phone Springer makes the best stuff so
they have this really nice sling bag so
it has everything in it with an
attachable matching leash and I love
these water bottles so you just squeeze
them and they fill up the bowl is
attached to a bottle you lock it it's
not going to spill all over and then
when you're done you just release and
whatever water is left is going to go
back down starting at 15 40 the deals
today 30 off I'm telling you this is a
game changer this is good as someone who
has had water leak all over or has
forgotten my dog's water and then
sacrificed my own for her because she's
the queen I got it for you at different
sizes really really nice now this is
something I can use okay anyone who has
traveled and I'm sure you know you just
got back from the book tour or you get
to your hotel your destination and your
jewelry is Tangled ah no more thanks to
traveler this is a vegan jewelry luggage
clutch you pull it out like you'd pull
down a shade look at eight different
places to hang your necklaces your
bracelets you can hang your earrings but
there's also a zip pouch up here you can
put your rings and arrows in there
79.99 today 65 off never have Tangled
jewelry again I can't believe it's taken
this long to have this solution I've
spent 20 minutes at the hotel and I love
that you could actually it comes with a
suction cup you could stick it to the
mirror or a glass
wall or you could hang it on a hook or a
hanger a game changer get those knots
out of those yes yes necklaces okay okay
can I eat now yes please this is take a
bite this is sweet kiss Brigadeiro this
is a mother-daughter company these are a
Brazilian take on truffles everybody
come in here my mom and I devoured an
entire kit so I'd say there's two
exclusive prices today forty dollars for
the instead of 15. 72 for the set of 30
get the bigger one if they're for you
because don't they just melt in your
mouth
ice cream a little bit right it is all
different flavors and you could
customize your box so if you're like I
like the coffee I like the caramel I
like the coconut yeah go for it go
whatever one you like I love we have
like workout gear here and then we have
chocolate yeah well you know a balance
life is balanced I really like the dolce
de leche one these are so good and
unlike anything else I've ever had
before great for Mother's Day birthday
yay beautiful presentation thank you so
much of course of course we partner with
all these companies to get these deals
so to buy anything you see right here
scan that QR code on your screen or head
on over to cbsdeals.com